my understanding is that you know there
there are people who are in these
agencies or in the FBI or in the doj who
do think Biden's corrupt who do think
that Hunter by the script that they're
doing these illicit deals but no one has
the balls to do anything I don't know
maybe project Veritas got to him maybe
Mike James O'Keefe constantly saying be
brave maybe the FBI whistleblowers who
came to James O'Keefe finally started
inspiring some people at the mid-level
who are like
we're gonna go take a look at the
president's house now that being said it
was it was Biden's aides and lawyers who
discovered and then released the
documents but it very well may be the
reason they're pursuing the search is
because there are people who are finally
like I'm done with this I'm gonna start
going into it and then why does pence
get hit
I wouldn't be surprised if it's because
the corruption is it's they're now
saying okay we're going after you we're
going to one up we're going through your
guys sure and I also wondered with uh
Biden's release like if his age is
either finding them are they just trying
to get out ahead of it